The gist of it is that learning
languages is good for you.
Any kind of brain
activity is good for you.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today,
and I want to talk about language
learning and dementia or Alzheimer's.
Uh, remember, if you enjoy
my videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So, the subject of old age and
dementia, Alzheimer's uh, it,
it comes up fairly frequently.
Uh, I think as people get older,
they're obviously, you know, concerned
that they might start showing
symptoms of Alzheimer's or dementia.
Uh, I think...
I'm 77 at times uh, I forget things.
I'm not sure whether I'm more
forgetful now than I was before.
I was always a little forgetful.
Uh, we tend to interpret any sort
of moments where we forget things
as an example of, uh, declining, you
know, brain function or whatever.
And to some extent, probably as we get
older, just as our bodies are not as, as
strong, uh, perhaps our brains are also
slowly, uh, you know, not functioning
as, as well as they did, uh, you know,
earlier on, but that's not the same as
obviously as as dementia or Alzheimer's.
So very often you hear that
learning another language can
help stave off Alzheimer's.
Not entirely clear whether this means
someone who already is bilingual or
multilingual and therefore has these
defenses against the onset of Alzheimer or
if someone takes up the study of languages
in old age or older, when they're older,
does that help stave off dementia?
And it's easy enough to Google and
look up, and you'll find a, a, a
variety of articles on this subject.
Uh, the gist of it is that
learning languages is good for you.
Any kind of brain
activity is good for you.
Doing Sudoku, playing the piano,
anything that activates the
brain cells is better for you.
Sitting in front of the television,
for example, um, which is not an
activity that engages the brain
a lot, reading actually does.
So any activity like that, I, I would
imagine, and I'm sure there's lots
of research on it, shows that you're
helping to delay the potential onset
of dementia in terms of evaluating, you
know, being bilingual or multilingual
or learning other languages and
the effect that has on dementia.
There are studies, percentage
improvement or, uh, you know, delay
the onset by a few years or whatever.
However, these studies, I don't think
they've done a good job of sort of
isolating for example, you know,
people in different socioeconomic
circumstances, uh, how well do you
actually have to speak the language for
it to have a, an effect or benefit you?
Is it enough that you were,
you know, bilingual as a kid?
Do you have to be continuing
to learn these languages?
There's so many unanswered
questions there, but I just
take it that it's good for you.
So learning languages is gonna
help you stave off dementia.
Uh, but there's another aspect to that
and to this and that is, it's not just
that you're learning languages and you're
activating certain parts of your brain.
I think it's the fact that if you
commit to learning a language at
my age, let's say, or even 10 years
younger or 10 years older, that
means you have a purpose in life.
So there seems, there's quite a
bit of research to show that it's
not even enough to be positive.
We all like to be positive, but actually
to feel you have a purpose and, uh, I feel
a sense of purpose in learning languages.
I enjoy doing it.
It gives me satisfaction and I,you
know, acquiring knowledge is a, a, a,
a perfectly legitimate purpose in life.
I just happen to be reading a book about
the history of Arabs written by Albert
Hourani, and he talks about Ibn Khaldun
the famous, uh, Arab, uh, traveler and
and writer in the maybe 14th century.
And, uh, he spent his mornings
working for the visa for the
government and in the afternoon he
studied, like that was his activity.
Learning learning is a
perfectly legitimate activity.
It's a constructive purpose.
And so if we have that purpose and we
feel that purpose, then we are less likely
to suffer from Alzheimer's it turns out.
Whereas people who don't have a
sense of purpose when they're older,
they're more likely to, you know,
have these kinds of, uh, difficulties.
So it's not enough just to be positive
because the positive can go up and down.
I was not that positive about my Arabic
because I wasn't making much progress.
And then strange things happen.
Amazon delivery, the
delivery man was from Yemen.
We speak a few words in Arabic, I'm
re-motivated, so then when I work
out on my treadmill, I go and grab...
or if I, I go to Netflix and find
an an Egyptian movie to watch.
And so all of a sudden I'm more
positive about my Arabic little things.
You know, sometimes you're a little
bit down because you can't remember
stuff, and then something happens to
make you more positive, but beyond
that having this sense that you have
a purpose, whatever that purpose may
be, uh, apparently is very powerful in
staving off the onset of Alzheimer's.
So couple that with the fact that
learning languages has some not
totally, clearly defined, beneficial
effect, uh, in providing you with, with
better defense against Alzheimer's.
Uh, I think those are very good reasons
for learning languages well into old age.
So I leave you with those thoughts.
I'd be interested in what you have
to say, and uh, it's just another
reason why language shorting
is such a good thing to do.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.